- Welcome back.
As we close our Veteran's Day show,
I have one more story to share.
This is what I'm liking.
David and Sylvia were
high school sweethearts
from Philadelphia.
In the wake of Pearl
Harbor, David enlisted
and was sent overseas.
He fought the Nazi army through
North Africa, Italy, France
and finally Germany.
Then he deployed to the Pacific Theater
for the final months of the war.
Meanwhile, Sylvia did her
part at the Philadelphia
Navy Yard helping build
ships for the war effort.
Everybody doing their part.
Before David returned home,
he wrote his sister to
buy a ring for Sylvia.
Come on now.
Sylvia agreed to marry
him and just 10 days
after he arrived home,
they exchanged vows.
76 years later,
they're still going strong.
Say hello to David and Sylvia
watching on NBC Fort Washington at two.
- [Kelly] Hello.
Hello, David.
Hello, Sylvia.
First, I just wanna say thank
you so much to both of you
your incredible service to this country.
Thank you, Thank you, thank you.
And David, you didn't waste any time.
So why was it so important to
get married when you got back?
- Well, you know, I was away
for four years
and, uh
made it okay, which there was some doubt
with everything that I
saw in both theaters.
Anyway,
I wanted to get out of the service.
I've been in long enough.
And start a family.
So that's basically, you know
you know how I felt about the whole thing.
- [Kelly] Yeah. So,
Sylvia, what's the secret
to a long marriage like yours?
I don't even know anybody that's
been married for 76 years.
Congratulations.
- Just live your life.
You respect each other and you go along
and have your wonderful family
and all your grandkids and so forth
and you don't even realize
that the time is going by.
And here we are.
- [David] I just wanna add one thing.
Respect.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That was the biggest thing.
You must respect one another
for as many years as you're
together and beyond that.
- Yeah. Finding a partner like that,
that's beautiful you guys.
Well, David, what do you
want people to remember
this Veteran's Day?
- I want them think about,
there's so many wonderful people that
lost their lives during the war.
I lost many, many very close buddies.
I just want there to be peace.
People should respect each other.
No more wars.
I know that's difficult to to say,
but this is it.
We don't need wars to
settle our differences.
- [Kelly] Amen. I'm with you, man.
Well, thank you so much, David.
Thank you, Sylvia, for taking the time.
I know you're not on social media,
but I'm still liking your
post right now, anyway.
And that's not all.
Our season long Partner
Pilot Pin makers of G2,
the go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson Show,
want to honor people like you,
who have given so much to this country.
So they're gonna be writing
you a check for $1,000.
That's David, that,
that is the second nudge
I've seen from Sylvia.
That was amazing.
That's the second nudge.
You gotta take her out on a date.
Thank you guys so much.
Y'all have a blessed day.
Thank you to all our guests this hour.
Jonathan Majors, Hospital
Corpsman, Tarika Harris, Sammy,
Greg Morgan, Staff
Sergeant Shaquel McKenna
and specialist Kevin Ortiz.
Y'all have a great day, and if it's not,
try and change it.